[Music]
is interesting one of our show sponsors
subway would like us to tell you about
their great new sub of the day deal
featuring a different 6-inch Subway
sandwich every day of the week for just
350 hey cone and what about the sweet
onion chicken teriyaki sandwich those
are my favorite well sure you [ __ ]
creep yeah they're this you leering
weirdo they're the subway stop of the
day on Mondays yeah but today's Thursday
I guess I have to no choice but to climb
into that highly experimental and
untested time machine over there travel
back in time to Monday and get a sweet
deal on one of those six-inch sweet
onion chicken teriyaki Subway sandwiches
well ok Andy or you could just wait till
Monday and just walk into any subway
location to get the same deal I can't
hear you I'm getting into a time machine
Oh from onion chicken teriyaki sandwich
here I come Oh God he's amped up about
this
what door takes forever to Andy no that
was stupid
wait who everybody involved that's
incredible you did it Andy yeah I just
got a sweet onion chicken teriyaki
Subway sandwich for just 350 yeah and
all you had to do was risk your life
with dangerous unproven technology yeah
who's the idiot now every teacher I've
ever had
don't bond if I oh woops grab it too
soon don't mind if I do doink in Lincoln
I'd like to put a bullet in your noggin
President Lincoln stole my sweet onion
chicken teriyaki sandwich worst
president ever well Andy I just hope
that very small incident doesn't change
history in any way too late Conan look
huh what though
oh no it's a horribly mutated phallus
well we'll get this madness sorted out
we'll be right back and then we go out
on we should bumper on us just standing
here yeah I think Abe should be chomping
away what L can prick I love this
I really am sure this is funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
you